i'm bret baer i'm maria bartoromo i'm
brian kilmeade and this is the fox news
rundown
friday july 15 2022 i'm jessica
rosenthal as inflation goes up the
president's poll numbers go down we've
seen some of the blame for the bad news
aimed at oil companies other countries
leaders the messengers doing the
messaging and even the press i do think
it's fair to say that a number of
reporters who were easy to cover on joe
biden but still when you watch that
briefing room it still is largely a home
game for the press secretary for joe
biden i'm chris foster fox sports
reporter tom rinaldi's new project is
about the murdered major league baseball
player lyman vostok obviously
the tragedy of his death and how he died
will always be a part of his story but
there's so much more to him which is
compelling
and i'm janis dean i've got the final
word on the fox news rundown
as inflation soars and the president's
poll numbers tank democrats are
scrambling and so is the white house at
least if you believe the headlines like
question swirl about white house
messaging after bettingfield's departure
democrats biden problem takes over
midterm messaging one even read why do
democrats suck at messaging those are
just a few of the headlines from the
last couple of months the president
himself told abc late night host jimmy
kimmel in june that his administration's
accomplished a lot they just haven't
been able to communicate it well to the
press one of the things is that it's
very difficult now
to have a
even
with notable exceptions even though
really good reporters they have to get
number clicks on on on nightly news so
instead of asking a question
anyway it just everything gets
gets sensationalized and when it comes
to the things that are not going well
like inflation and high energy prices
the president's message has been varied
the overwhelming consensus is going to
pop up a little bit and then go back
down the inflation has everything to do
with the supply chain
make no mistake inflation is largely the
fault of putin while some of the
messengers have left including jen saki
and now white house communications
director kate bettingfield those who
remain have been on defense economic
adviser jared bernstein went on with fox
business anchor neil cavuto this week
after the latest inflation data came out
i'm saying more investment is the answer
more investment in production right and
that might or might not be the solution
but spending efforts have not really
helped this is actually working right
you raise a really important distinction
you know you like to focus on the
headwinds and i get it if it bleeds it
leads i understand that i think it's
unreality but there have also been some
increasingly tense moments inside the
white house briefing room over things
like the baby formula shortage and even
when the president had last tested
negative for covid boy is this
administration struggling and they're
struggling because that they're out of
touch and what's gone wrong are their
policies ari fleischer used to be in the
white house briefing room regularly as a
former white house spokesman for
president george w bush he's also now a
fox news contributor it's not a
communications issue it's not a press
secretary issue or a communications
director issue it's a joe biden issue he
made the decisions he launched the
policies that helped give a huge boost
to inflation he opened the southern
border the prosecutors that he won't
criticize to the ones who've opened the
country to crime and it's all because
he's governed differently than he
promised he's governed from the
progressive woke left instead of the
sensible center
what do you foresee
i guess this year happening as a result
of that i mean especially when we look
ahead and to the midterms
well our democracy has always breathed
through the expression of the voters in
the form of elections
and in just four months now less than
four months i think you can anticipate a
massive blowout defeat for the democrats
the first midterm of any president's
term is historically tough
combine that with a terribly unpopular
president with a nation that's largely
seen as being on the wrong track and
inflation that's sky high
and the democrats are going to lose the
house they're likely going to lose the
senate in state legislative races and
judicial races throughout the 50 states
democrats are going to get clobbered
this is shaping up like a 2010 or 2014
repudiation of barack obama which was
massive and now it's going to happen to
joe biden too i want to ask about what
the president has said about gas prices
because he said refineries are making
record profits and that they need to
increase capacity the oil and gas
industry said we are operating at
capacity that weather and covid took
some refineries offline
and this administration keeps talking
about renewables so we're not going to
invest in reopening those refineries put
yourself back at the lectern for a
moment when you have jeff bezos calling
out your administration's ability to
understand oil markets and you have the
u.s oil and gas association mocking your
administration for having an intern post
a tweet and telling them to go back to
college to take econ 101
what would you do how would you respond
well i wouldn't work at this white house
i will not be at that podium trying to
explain something that cannot be
explained
you know the democrats fundamental
problem when it comes to energy is
this is what they want the higher the
prices for oil the higher the prices for
gas the more solar and renewables can
compete
so this is a result of what they want
but they're caught
because they can't say it's what they
want because it's hurting consumers it's
heard in the middle class it's hurting
everybody who has to heat a home air
conditioning a home or drive a car
so this is of their own doing
but they want to have it both ways but
make no mistake if you support the green
new deal if you want to get off of oil
and get off of gas you need oil and gas
to be sky high in terms of price so
that's why they closed the keystone
pipeline that's why they don't allow
permits on federal lands
that's why they vilify the oil and gas
industry which hurts their ability to
invest long term i don't see the
administration trying to work with the
private sector to open new refineries
so it's all hypocrisy because
for the green new deal this is what you
want
all right finally the january 6th
hearings are happening we've heard from
quite a few people um it's been reported
that after mark meadow's aide cassidy
hutchinson testified other people
started to come forward
and we know
recently
wyoming republican congresswoman liz
chaney one of the two republicans on
this january 6 committee said
that all of this may very well lead to a
referral to the justice department
against president trump
does that happen and if it does
what happens after that
first of all a referral means nothing
congress has referred half a dozen to a
dozen people in the last few years for
referrals to the justice department
republicans did it to trump people and
now democrats are doing it it doesn't
matter the only thing that matters is
what department of justice does and
that'll be a huge decision if they try
to indict donald trump
i'd be shocked if they do that
but you know everything about the riot
on january 6 was wrong
no one regardless of cause has an excuse
to riot no one regardless of cause
should attack the police no one should
trespass no one should do the things
that were done at the capitol that day
january 6th
but i have not learned a single new
thing as a result of these january 6
hearings no wonder the democrats want to
focus backwards their future is so
difficult for them because of inflation
and economics and the bread and butter
issues that the american people care
about they need a distraction and these
hearings are their distraction all right
let's talk about your book suppression
deception snobbery and bias why the
press gets so much wrong and just
doesn't care
you do open by recalling a cnn segment
in which don lemon and his guests mock
trump supporters for not knowing i guess
basic things right um putting on a fake
southern accent not knowing where
ukraine is
tell me about that and what motivated
you largely was it the media's reaction
to trump and his supporters
it was a hundred percent reaction to the
way the press was covering donald trump
as i sat there and watched it and i try
to be a fair-minded individual i try to
call the balls and strikes but when i
watch the press vilify donald trump in
the snobbery the disdain with which they
look down on donald trump supporters
i just saw that the press has lost its
way
america for our democracy we need a
neutral and objective press i don't care
if the press likes someone or doesn't
like someone they need to be neutral
they need to be objective and they
abandoned their duties to the american
people and their coverage of donald
trump
the mainstream press too many of them
decided that the american people were
wrong when they elected donald trump and
that the press's job was to right the
wrong and so therefore they deceived the
american people but countless stories on
the air that were not true from steele
dossier to collusion to trump stealing
blue mailboxes to steal the election
the press has become activists and i
blow a whistle on it that's why i wrote
the book this is the reckoning the press
deserves needs but will not do for
themselves
you and i both know there's a difference
between talk shows and what reporters do
i'm a reporter um sean hannity and laura
ingram those are talk show hosts
when you were researching your book and
you were
looking at examples
what did you find in your assessment of
reporters rather than talk show hosts
that you found to be i guess most
troubling
great question and i make an allowance
for that there is such a thing as
opinion people and sean's the first to
admit he's an opinion reporter don lemon
would claim he's an objective reporter
despite the fact that he's not
but what i found and there's a chapter
on cnn and a chapter in the new york
times on my book that cnn's daytime
reporters just let their opinions rip
all you have to do is watch jim acosta
in the white house briefing room giving
his opinions about what public policy
should be all you had to do was watch
john harwood see it as white house
reporter giving his blatant biased
opinions which he sounded like a
spokesman for the democrat national
committee and i asked myself how can
these cnn reporters daytime
correspondents be doing that and it's
because the management scene and wanted
them to
they wanted their reports to become
activists they rejoiced in the number of
twitter followers their reporters had
they rejoiced how many hollywood
celebrities praised their reporters for
being biased and anti-trump and it led
cnn to having them leading the league
and the number of retracted stories that
cnn put on the air
how do you think the press score is done
treating this administration because it
does seem like there have been some
exchanges especially with gensake out
and queen john pierre in um over the
baby formula shortage and
i remember even when the president um
they got into it over when the president
last tested negative for kovid i think
like four reporters
kept insisting why won't you just tell
us when he last tested negative um it
does seem like a press corps that is
growing a little bit more frustrated
with this administration
yeah you know from the day joe biden on
south carolina primary
until the withdrawal from afghanistan
the press
could not have been easier on joe biden
one of the things i cite in my book is a
study of the last five presidents
and how much the press was negative or
positive in their first 60 days joe
biden got the most positive easiest
press of any of the five predecessors
including barack obama
since the withdrawal from afghanistan i
do think it's fair to say that a number
of reporters who were easy have got
tougher on joe biden but still when you
watch that briefing room it still is
largely a home game for the press
secretary and for joe biden very few
reporters are tough on this
administration when i was in that room
in that room at 49 seats all 49 were
tough
devil's advocate hard questions against
me against president bush right now i'd
say there's maybe 35 40 who go easy
maybe 5 10 who ask regular tough
questions
and that's just not the way it should be
too many reporters have enjoyed their
role as being advocates and partisans
and they need to return and this is
leadership to
objectivity and neutrality is it
leadership or is it
is it leadership re or is it education
you also talk about interviewing and
talking with young journalists and
universities where does this then start
it starts in journalism school with with
the attracted journalism school you know
one of the points i make in my book is
how biased journalism schools are so
right from the start journalism has an
original sin the people who go into
journalism are overwhelmingly cut from
the same cloth college-educated
democratic voters
and one study i found reported in my
book is the only group of americans who
think the press understands them are
college educated democrats
so in essence journalism has become
college-educated democrat reporters
writing stories that are only
interesting to college educated democrat
readers and viewers so it starts with
recruitment to journalism schools is
leadership in news rooms that presents
other sides of thinking
that anticipates that donald trump could
have won in 2016
that doesn't just dismiss republicans
conservatives and populists out of hand
as a bunch of wackos who are missing the
front two which is what many of them
look at and think
so it's up and down the journalism chain
so that people can say when i read the
paper this morning
i believed what i read all right
fleischer thank you so much for your
time and your insight we appreciate it
it's great to be with you thank you
[Music]
this is janis dean with your fox news
commentary coming up
tom rinaldi's a reporter for fox sports
working the sidelines during nfl
coverage he's covered some of the
biggest events in sports pro and college
football golf tennis horse racing the
olympics besides live sports coverage
tom's known for his award-winning
original storytelling the story he tells
in a new audio documentaries about a
major league baseball player murdered in
1978
there were shocked reactions today from
the baseball world to the shooting death
of california angels outfielder lyman
bostock last night
lyman wesley bostock jr was 27 years old
when he died this isn't my first
go-round with lyman's story tom
renaldi's new fox sports podcast series
is called wesley starts on monday i had
the opportunity to first tell it 14
years ago as a television feature at
espn
and there was so much more to lyman's
story that we weren't able to cover in
the initial story that we did
that was a big driver in wanting to
revisit it but another one was a
powerful regret that i've carried here
for those 14 years
in
botching an encounter i had with the man
who killed lyman bostock the only player
to be murdered
in season in the history of major league
baseball we found the man that killed
him leonard smith
and i just mishandled it and that sort
of sat with me and that's a part of the
later episodes here of the podcast as we
revisit that okay well good for you for
getting another chance to i know those i
know those kind of regrets and you don't
often get a chance to
to erase them uh so i would listen to
the podcast and see exactly what you
think you mishandled um
lemon boss like i know of him may
probably unfairly like a lot of people
just for
his murder he was actually a really
interesting guy and a really good
ballplayer obviously
the tragedy of his death and how he died
will always be a part of his story but
there's so much more to him which is
compelling start with his excellence as
a player
his premium as a performer
career 311 hitter that's the same
batting average as jackie robinson it's
higher than players like rod crew and
i'm a player like george brett
but
he also was a ichiro-like character in
the batter's box could hit to all fields
ran with great speed was an excellent
outfielder
being a 595th pick in the mlb draft and
ultimately making it
so many aspects to his journey which are
fascinating well beyond the way that he
died well let's talk about how he died
to really simplify it it was a jealous
husband right talk about what happened
that night
september 23rd 1978 lyman had spent part
of his childhood growing up in gary
indiana had a lot of family back there
who would come and see him whenever he
played in chicago
and he was playing a series with the
angels against the chicago white sox at
comiskey park
lyman goes back to gary has a family
dinner and while there brings up a
childhood friend who he had read to when
he was much younger
his uncle said she lives just a few
blocks away lymon went with his uncle to
visit that woman and that woman's sister
happened to be there barbara smith and
she
was estranged from her husband leonard
and that's what puts into motion what
ultimately happens when leonard smith
misinterprets seeing lyman bostock
give his his estranged wife a ride along
with lyman's uncle and a friend
across town
pulls up a long side at an intersection
and that's where lyman's life ends
yeah i mean he wasn't even remotely
seeing the guy's wife and
uh
in that way not at all so what was what
was the defense uh it was a what most
people say was an egregiously short
sentence talk about his uh how his case
played out so not only do we does the
podcast explore
the improbability of of lyman and his
rise his being really on the cusp of
stardom in major league baseball and the
fact that he was one of the highest paid
players in the game in 1978
but what happens in the aftermath of his
shooting
where
leonard smith's mother
finds a way to pay for
basically
one of the best defense attorneys
throughout indiana a man named nick
theros
and nick theros who chooses to employ a
not guilty by reason of insanity defense
and the podcast takes you through not
one but two trials that leonard smith
faces
and ultimately the verdict that's
reached which lands leonard smith who is
clearly identified chris as the shooter
not doesn't dispute that doesn't dispute
that he fired a four ton a 410 board
shotgun
into the back seat of a car at close
range
but
that he wasn't in his right mind at the
time because he was so
jealous
yeah somehow
a jury
finds that plausible
eleven boston he came up with a
minnesota twins uh had three really good
years i guess and then free agency was a
relatively new thing then and like
like like you said so he was
famous not just for his plays wasn't
quite an all-star yet but on his way to
becoming one if not a hall of famer some
people say but he'd sign this huge
contract well we say huge then uh six
years 2.3 million dollars so that's
about 383 000 a year i looked it up it's
about 1.7 million
uh in today's dollars which you know the
most marginal major leaguers make but at
the time it was big news huge and the
fact that he had chosen he was pursued
vigorously by
a lot of big teams
his chief pursuer was the new york
yankees run then by the boss george
steinbrenner who had asked reggie
jackson to be involved in lyman's
recruitment
there's an anecdote in one of the
episodes in which someone shows up
representing the yankees who offers
lyman bostock a couple of hundred
thousand dollars to consider
their contract offer
as a show of quote-unquote good faith
lyman does not take that check
and
he chooses to play for the angels and as
i'm sure you know chris what unfolds in
the first month of his career in the
fourth season of his career
is stunning he feels this overwhelming
weight of making that money being one of
the highest paid players in the sport
and tanks
he bats under 150
in his first month
goes to gene autry the famous singing
cowboy who was then the owner of the
angels
and refused his salary saying he didn't
think he had earned it
uh the angels say we're going to pay you
lymon you know we're contractually bound
to do so
lymon
receives the money
and gives it away to charity
all of it for the month
uh just shy of fifty thousand dollars
at that time
for a player who the previous season had
made twenty thousand for the entire year
was a powerful powerful gesture
something which got a ton of attention
uh let me ask you about uh just a couple
things in the sports world number one uh
what are your thoughts on the live
golf league now that's that's throwing
all these money uh
all this money it guys it's a little bit
relevant in the news president biden is
uh going to be visiting saudi arabia or
is visiting saudi arabia um have you
talked about it with uh with some of the
players i've texted with a couple of the
players i think a couple of things here
chris just simply put one is
that there is a i wouldn't say it's an
existential threat by any means but it
is a systemic
issue for the pga tour and and this is
not going to break any news
because as a sports fan you know that
four events
dominate golf the other events are
wonderful listen i love bay hill i love
the memorial i've i've covered those
events
but the the us open the masters the open
championship and the pga championship
there's a huge question here will
players receive world golf ranking
points and be able to qualify to play in
those events which have the most
prestige the most
historical weight the most meaning and
if they can
and still be guaranteed this kind of
fortune to play in quote unquote regular
season events
there's going to continue to be a strong
pull
toward players later in their career
players who have been dealing with
injury who are going to be guaranteed a
totally different level of financial
security
that's a fascinating dynamic they'll
have to see how that unfolds yeah some
guys may have to in the end choose do i
want the money or do i want the prestige
um one more
gambling has now become a big part of
mainstream sports coverage it used to be
uh you know people would bet with
bookies and whatever and but the
professional sports the big leagues
uh would really try to keep the whole
thing at more than an arm's length and
now it's just being welcome do you have
any thoughts about it as a broadcaster
you know
the pull and force
of sports betting and gambling
is massive
it is a massive part of sports fandom of
the sports landscape
and i just think that there was an
inevitability of leagues recognizing
that
trying to figure out ways in which they
could build that relationship in a way
that could be governed and monetized and
that's what i think we've seen
you know what i know it's been a part of
sport fandom forever
and if the leagues feel that they can
govern this
they can codify it in a way that
preserves the integrity of the game
obviously huge question
then they're going to find a way to
monetize a massive revenue stream which
has been untapped to this point well
thanks for talking to us today it was it
was a pleasure a new documentary called
wesley that's lyman bostock's middle
name uh wesley's an audio documentary
about um the murder baseball player
lyman wesley bostock jr it's on the fox
sports podcast networks available monday
uh eight episodes how do you do it you
put them all out at once or you drive
and drive it so yeah and it's available
everywhere chris on on apple on spotify
on all the platforms where you would
download and listen to you anywhere you
get your podcasts first four episodes
this coming monday july 18
then episode five and six the following
monday and episodes seven and eight the
monday after that so the entirety of the
series will be out in the span of three
weeks but the first four episodes july
18. we really hope people give it a
listen um and and and really learn about
a remarkable story of a remarkable man
who has been
largely
overlooked tom ronaldi fox sports uh
enjoy the all-star game in la coming up
uh
on tuesday i i hear you have a feature
on aaron judge i assume the angle is
just that he hits baseball's very very
far
[Laughter]
tom is good to talk to you thank you
chris
[Music]
jason in the house the jason chaffetz
podcast dive deeper than the headlines
in the party lines as i take on american
life politics and entertainment
subscribe now on
foxnewspodcast.com or wherever you
download podcasts
subscribe to this podcast at fox news
foxnewspodcasts.com
and now some good news with tanya j
powers
[Music]
among the events that covet 19 pandemic
derailed or scaled back were weddings
lots and lots of weddings so an iconic
new york city location decided to give i
do a do-over
500 couples who found themselves putting
off or paring down their big day
gathered at lincoln center for the
performing arts for celebrate love a
re-wedding the multicultural ceremony
which was not legally binding featured
music from broadway stars dancing and a
10-foot disco ball
some couples were celebrating new
relationships while others renewed their
vows many with family and friends just
like the big day they originally set out
to have
tanya j powers fox news
[Music]
it's time for your fox news commentary
janice dean
what's on your mind in october of 2021
new york governor kathy hokel met with
grieving families who lost loved ones in
nursing homes during the covet 19
pandemic i was with my husband sean
whose parents mickey and dee were among
the over 15 000 seniors who died from
contracting the virus in their long-term
care facilities i remember feeling
optimistic that if she heard our stories
and saw our grief first hand she would
help us find answers the day of the
meeting she listened to us offered her
condolences and promised to be fully
transparent to help us get to the bottom
of what happened in the spring of 2020
at the time
i believed her but now over two years
later we still don't know why andrew
cuomo and the new york health department
ordered over 9 000 covet 19 positive
patients into their residences without
alerting our families the administration
never took responsibility for their
reckless decisions and death toll
cover-up there is now strong evidence
that andrew cuomo purposely hid these
numbers to profit from a five million
dollar book he was writing about
leadership during the pandemic hochel
listened sympathetically to my husband
sean as he painfully explained what it
was like losing both of his parents
within two weeks of each other and not
being able to see or comfort them my
friends peter and daniel arbini gave
hogel their father's death certificate
and asked why he wasn't counted in the
whitewash of nursing home fatalities i
commented after our meeting that
houkel's actions would speak louder than
words and almost a year later we have
seen nothing to indicate she has been
true to her promise to help grieving
families this past week there have been
a chorus of newspaper editorials from
the new york post the daily news and the
times union asking why kathy hokel is
dragging her heels on her promised blue
ribbon panel to go through all the good
bad and ugly decisions that were made
during the pandemic here in new york my
friend and fellow advocate new york
state assemblyman ron kim who helped
facilitate the meeting between grieving
families in hoca last year is still
holding out hope that she will be true
to her word but argues this can't be a
review by consultants that she chooses
to do the report it needs to be an
independent commission with full
subpoena and investigative powers in the
meantime families like mine are trying
to figure out what we can do on our own
one thing that we're counting on is the
passage of the new york state senate
bill
s-74-a
known as the grieving families act this
legislation would help in future
lawsuits when a loved one's life
wrongfully ends and consider the
emotional loss when awarding damages the
bill would also increase the statute of
limitations to file a claim giving
families the chance to have their day in
court however the bill if it's past
would also require action and a
signature from the very same governor
kathy hokel
i wish i could be more optimistic but if
history is our guide the same woman who
looked us in the eye and told us she
cared and wanted to help has so far done
nothing to make us believe her
i'm janice dean
fox news senior meteorologist and host
of the janisteen podcast that you can
find starting monday at
foxnewspodcast.com
you've been listening to the fox news
rundown
stay up to date by subscribing to this
podcast at
foxnewspodcasts.com and for up to the
minute news go to foxnews.com
[Music]
fox news radio on demand on the fox news
app download the app and just click
listen when you swipe left you can
listen to your favorite fox news talk
shows live swipe right for the latest
fox news radio newscasts on demand fox
news radio and the fox news app download
it today
love fox news click the subscribe button
to get more of the news and opinion you
trust and click the fox news rundown
playlist for the latest episodes